on va écouter vladimir poutine tout de
suite qui s'adresse à la télévision
laissons les événements tout en ukraine
et pourquoi c'est aussi important pour
nous pour la russie
bien sûr
je m'adresse aussi à nos compatriotes en
ukraine
donc je voudrais m'adresser à vous de
manière très détaillée aujourd'hui est
très sérieusement la situation dans le
donbass est aujourd'hui au point
critique le plus mouche et aujourd'hui
je m'adresse à vous directement pour
donner une estimation de ce qui se passe
mais aussi pour vous informer des
décisions que je veux du chantre par la
suite
encore une fois je voudrais répéter que
l'ukraine ce n'est pas seulement notre
voisin mais c'est également une partie
de notre histoire de notre espace
culturel se sont noués du proche
nombreux collègues ce sont nos amis mais
ce sont aussi les gens de notre famille
nous avons les liens de sang avec ces
personnes jeudi le réseau depuis très
longtemps ce du mur des partis et des
habitants
des territoires au sud-ouest lésés par 6
du même peuple s'était déjà à l'époque
où ces territoires ont
rejoint la russie il y a eu des siècles
donc tout le monde connaît cette
histoire ce sont des faits est connu par
tout le monde
comprendre ce qui se passe aujourd'hui
pour expliquer les motivations de la
russie je pense qu'il faut parler quand
même revenir
l'historique de
ce sujet tout d'abord l ukraine moderne
a été créé entièrement de toutes pièces
par la russie par la russie des
bolchéviques jeu par la russie
communiste ce processus a commencé
pratiquement tout de suite après la
révolution de 1917
d'ailleurs les wind et ses compagnons
n'ont fait de manière assez brutale
vis-à-vis de la russie c'est à dire qui
et les autres séparé de la russie ils
ont coupé une partie des territoires où
historiquement aux russes et des
millions des personnes qui vivaient sur
sept territoires n'ont pas pu exprimer
leur avis
ensuite à laver de la seconde guerre
patriotique et après la guerre
patriotique
sahlin a rajouté des terres qui
appartenaient à la pologne à la roumanie
et la hongrie et c'était en quelques
sortes de compensations
en donnant la pologne des parties des
territoires allemande est ensuite crush
à face aux russes la tri mais hélas
donné à l'ukraine voilà comment s'est
formé le territoire de l'ukraine
soviétique
et maintenant je devrai également vous
parler de la période des tout débuts de
l'existence de l'urss et c'est très
important de revenir à ses débuts donc
devenir bien en arrière depuis le coup
d'état de 1906 est et ensuite de la
guerre civile les bolchéviques ont
commencé à bâtir en nouvel état et il
avait d'ailleurs des dissensions assez
sévère en 1922 d'aline était à la fois
le secrétaire général du rpp et aussi le
commissaire du peuple aux du peuple des
nationalités
proposé
l'autonomisation c'est à dire qu'il a
proposé aux républiques et aux régions
autonomes à sculpter une grande
autonomie
mais il y avait également d'autres
pouvoirs
lénine notamment qu' on disait ce qui
était très critique vis-à-vis de cela
donc à l'époque quand on construisait
les union soviétique
ça a été déjà à la base en 1922 on a
créé l'urss et après à la mort de lénine
dans la constitution de l'urss on a
introduit cette question d'autonomie et
on se pose beaucoup de questions et là
parce que question plus principale
pourquoi on l'a fait pour le toit et il
y avait besoin de répondre et de 5,6
terre c'est l'ambition
nationaliste parce que dans ces
républiques
soviétiques
avaient des camps territoire et on leur
a ajouté à cause de ses ambitions pour
satisfaire ses ambitions en ajouter des
territoires et on a donné un statut et
la forme des formations étatique assez
aux unités question pourquoi il fallait
faire ses cadeaux généreux et au des
nationalistes radicaux ainsi ont pu être
satisfaites
donc on a donné à l'ukraine ce droit
d'avoir un statut d'état donc il y a une
explication pourquoi ça a été tu es
après la révolution les bolchéviques
voulait à tout prix garder le pouvoir je
souligne à tout prix c'est pour cela
qu'ils ont été prêt à tout et à
la montée de brest
l'allemagne de
l'allemagne et ses alliés étaient déjà
dans l'éducation très difficile et on
connaissait la vend pratiquement ce de
la première guerre mondiale met donc il
était prêt à satisfaire n'importe quelle
demande des nationalistes donc ces
principes de la construction de l'état
appliqué par l'énigme était une grosse
erreur mais bien plus que cela
en 1991 à la dissolution de leur essai
c'est devenu évident que c'était une
grosse erreur on ne pouvait plus changer
le passé mais aujourd'hui nous devons
homme cependant dire honnêtement
ce qui s'est passé sans essayer de le
camoufler
du coup sûr les teams de manière où le
politique
aujourd'hui
on peut dire que il n'ya jamais
on ne doit se fier justement à ses
désirs ambitions politiques du moment
pour prendre des décisions aussi
importantes au mieux je ne fais je ne
veux accuser personne évidemment cette
époque la situation était extrêmement
complexe et critique
aujourd'hui je dois vous dire que ce
sont des faits historiques c'est comme
cela que ça c'est du passé et donc suite
à cette politique des polémiques on a
créé l'ukraine soviétique
donc c'est l'ukraine du nom de vladimir
ilitch lénine c'est son auteur et c'est
son architecte etc
cela peut être démontrée par les
documents des archives est d'ailleurs
lénine a donné les directions concrètes
concernant nous donne le dong vaste
et aujourd'hui
les descendants reconnaissant ont
construit des monument à lénine dans ces
territoires donc c'était la
décommunisation
bien sûr nous sommes d'accord découle me
disais mais il ne faut pas il ne faut
pas s'arrêter à mi chemin et continuer
ce processus
mais je voudrais revenir encore une fois
dans l'histoire
1922 donc dans l'espace de l'ancien
empire russe on a créé
l'union soviétique l'urss mais tout de
suite
on a vu que c'était très complexe de
gérer ce grand territoire ces
territoires à mort fin et il n'y avait
pas aller le lien avec les traditions
bleu
donc ensuite il ya eu l'époque de la
terreur de staline la nationalisation le
système planifié de l'économie donc tout
cela à menu les
au fait que les principes qui ont été
déclarés de cette construction étatique
n'ont pas pu fonctionner c'est à dire
que c'est république n'ont pas pu avoir
de vraie souveraineté en pratique ce
qu'on a créé c'est un système très
centralisé donc c'était un état unitaire
staline a pratiquement réalisé sa vision
et non pas la vision de lignine de
construction de l'état
mais on n'a pas fait de modifications à
la constitution et les principes qui ont
été déclarées par les mines n'ont pas
été encore formellement l'étape démenti
mais de toute façon c'était un régime
totalitaire donc cela fonctionnait de
toute façon et de l'extérieur on avait
une bonne image d'un pays démocratique
mais quand même il est à déplorer
on n'a pas pu
bouger toutes ces idées dans les bases
juridiques ce sont des principes tout à
fait fantaisistes on n'a pas réfléchi à
l'avenir comme d'habitude les leaders du
parti communiste était persuadé qu'ils
avaient réussi politique monté un
système de
gestion très solide et ils ont dû régler
la question des nationalités
mais en ce qui concerne les
falsifications
et les mensonges a
toujours eu l'esprit
payer donc le nationalisme à ce mal
cette maladie
a prospecté donc c'était une ligne qui
est exposée
ensuite
c'est
pour cela que le s
échouer a été démantelé donc comme
depuis les années 80 il y avait de plus
en plus d'appétit des compétiteurs et
liste locale mais la direction du parti
communiste de l'urss au lieu de faire
une analyse globale de l'économie au
lieu de transformer le système politique
et l'étape du ils ont continué
à parler du principe de l'hymne aux deux
l'autodétermination nationale et
dans le parti communiste y avait des
divergences et les différentes parties
ont commencé à stimuler au contraire les
zooms différentes aux visions et idées
nationalistes donc c'était au départ
les deux l'économie du passage à le jeu
à l'économie du marché mais personne
qui était au pouvoir ne penser aux
autres conséquences tragiques de ces
événements et ensuite on a
continué à
suivre ce chemin de satisfaire les
ambitions
nationaliste de ses élites
mais ils ont oublié qu'ils n'avaient
plus des instruments pour garder le
pouvoir les instruments comme ceux
staline c'est à dire la terreur et puis
ils n'ont pas vu que le rôle du parti
communiste n'était plus le rôle du parti
leader et vous allez en septembre
4,9 lors de la plénière du parti
communiste on a adopté la plateforme du
kps s du parti communiste de l'urss
je cite les républiques
de l'union 11 tous les droits des états
ouvrant sa hutte socialiste
encore autre chose les organes
supérieurs de ces républiques ce mot
peuvent aller à l'encontre des décisions
du gouvernement de l'urss est encore
chaque république
union à
la possibilité de donner la citoyenneté
al les citoyens de cette république ont
la citoyenneté de cette république voilà
les
donc aujourd'hui
maintenant on ne va pas parler des
détails du droit constitutionnel mais je
vous pose la question du mois il a fallu
dans ces conditions difficiles
des mentionné
faire cette déconstruction de l'état
donc en fait avant le démantèlement de
l'urss le désirant ou de leurs essais
s'étaient déjà scellé
aujourd'hui les différentes personnes en
ukraine notamment disent que c'est grâce
à u que le pays a gagné
l'indépendance mais en réalité ce n'est
pas comme ça
c'est arrivé à cause des erreurs des
bolchéviques et des leaders du parti
communiste kke aps
la l'échec de leur essai ce
démantèlement de l'urss
c'est de leur faute
non car malgré cet échec à
notre peuple il ne peut pas reconnu les
réalités il a reconnu ses nouveaux états
indépendants et pas seulement et les ont
reconnus même m ils ont aidé ses
partenaires de la série de la communauté
des états indépendants et y compris ils
ont aidé l'ukraine l'ukraine envoyé
plusieurs demandent une aide financière
et notre pays a vraiment respecter la
souveraineté de l'ukraine et a aidé ce
pays les experts s'étaient font les
calculs en se basant sur les prix de
l'énergie
la russie a donné des régimes
préférentiels et depuis 80 ans jusqu'en
250 milliards de dollars voilà le
bénéfice que le cren à tirer de ces
les dettes de leurs essais ce
vis-à-vis de l'extériorité je sens une
île ja rule dollar
au début il était question que toutes
les républiques de l'ex urss de manière
sous les solidaires est proportionnelle
à les rembourser ses dettes cependant la
russie a décidé
de rendre cette dette internationale
tout seul est entièrement et la physique
de le faire en ce début 2010
et au les
républiques les ex républiques de l'urss
en
94 ont signé des accords
pour justement
renoncer à leurs amis chiffres mais ils
ont ensuite refusé l'ukraine a refusé de
renoncer à ses actifs sains à l'étranger
notamment en ce qui concerne des ponts
de diamants et des devises mais plus
malgré tout cela la russie à continuer à
coopérer avec le grain de manière
ouverte et honnête en respectant ses
intérêts et on avait beaucoup de
partenariats en 2008 plus de 50
milliards de dollars ça c'est les
volumes des échanges économiques
en 2019 avant la pandémie
nous avions moins de volume des échanges
avec toute l'union européenne
cependant le gouvernement
kenyan où je faisais tout pour avoir
tous les droits dans ses relations avec
la russie mais ne pas avoir d'
engagement donc ce n'était plus vieux
partenariat
c'était au contraire se servir de
manière éhontée
de tous ces privilèges notamment cela
concerne le gaz tout simplement le vol
du gaz voilà ce que les rênes faisait et
on essayait ou d'utiliser là
le dialogue avec moscou dans les
relations avec l'occident faire du
commerce justement faire eu peur du
rapprochement imminent vers peur à
l'occident de se rapprocher de la rue
c'est nul donc ils ont commencé à
construire leur état en
réfutant tout ce qui nous unit en
réfutant cette mémoire des générations
entières il n'est pas étonnant
alors
qu
on a vu naître la russophobie et le
néonazisme
et au cela je ressemble au but devant
des néo nazis
dans le caucase du nord du sud
évidemment il y avait aussi des forces
extérieures
jouer leur rôle notamment à travers des
organisations non gouvernementales
on y
important de souligner que l'ukraine n'a
jamais eu une offre beaucoup de
traditions
de l'état est depuis 91 élèves essayer
d'appliquer deux modèles extérieurs qui
ne se base pas sur les réalités et
craignait les institutions politiques et
étatiques été transformé en fonction des
appétits des collants et de leur intérêt
qu'ils n'avaient rien à voir avec les
intérêts du
nom qu'on part j'ai dû choisir isa
sionnel au occidentale mais ne
s'agissait pas de créer de meilleures
conditions pour le peuple kényan il
s'agissait
[Musique]
de garder pour soi même des milliards de
dollars pour les oligarques il est gardé
sur des comptes à l'étranger
et donc depuis toujours le gouvernement
s'appuyait sûr pas les nationalistes et
les radicaux
ensuite invité du bourg est il y avait
onze des millions des gens au sud et à
l'est qui réclamait
lui multilinguisme par exemple et les
différents pour laetitia s'appuyer sur
cette personne proclamer
la
soutient ou de l'utilisation des deux
langues ensuite dès qu'elles parvenaient
à leur chose du gouvernement oublier les
jeux directement niveau de tout cela
donc ils oublient et de renoncer à
l'agression
les radicaux étaient de plus en plus
arrogants ils savaient de plus en plus
de réclamations
discours pour eux ce n'était pas
compliqué d'année en année dans poser
leur vision des choses à ce gouvernement
le gouvernement qui était fun donc comme
à la place de leur lutte pour la
souveraineté
réelle de l'ukraine ils poursuivent et
des attributs vide de sens donc tout
cela c'est du rhône était comme
auparavant pour en réalité se partager
le pouvoir entre les différents clans
des oligarques de corruption c'est un
défi bien sûr pour beaucoup de pays pour
la russie aussi mais en une semaine la
corruption et à une échelle tout à fait
particulière elle transperce tout le
système de l'état du pouvoir les
radicaux site utilisé ce mécontentement
du peuple en 2014
amaidan on assure ce
d'état d'ailleurs ces radicaux ont reçu
une aide directe de l'étranger
et notamment
quand de prenois d'une mule reste à
terre a reçu en millions de dollars ou
par jour des états unis pour les
soutenir et on le voyait c'était
vraiment fait de manière arrogante des
donc c'est cet argent a été directement
virée sur les comptes de ces personnes
est d'ailleurs il ya eu
aussi des victimes et ya eu des morts
lors de ces événements les radios ont
réussi à parvenir au pouvoir ils ont
commencé la vraie terreur contre leurs
opposants les politiciens les
journalistes les personnes de société
civile ils les ont humilié publiquement
et la violence et les romains ont envahi
les villes et villages de l'ukraine
de la tragédie dos des sages ou les
personnes ont été brûlées vifs dans leur
rôle des protestations et les criminels
qui sont coupables de ces absences n'ont
pas été retrouvés on ne les cherche pas
mais on les connaît on connaît leurs
noms on fera tout pour les punir on va
les trouver et on va les traduire en
justice
le maidana pas rapproché l'ukraine à la
démocratie et au progrès de ces forces
nationalistes air eau ont au contraire
mené le traîne dans une impasse
et
depuis huit ans le pays est divisé il ya
une crise sociale j'ai dû très sévère
à bout en 2010 juge
presque 6 millions des yeux craignant
cela vaut aussi
pour semble de toute la population pas
seulement de la population active ont
été obligés de partir à l'étranger pour
chercher du travail
souvent au ces il s'agissait du travail
non qualifié
encore en fait depuis 2000 ventes juste
plus de
ses médecins ont quitté le pays dans les
conditions de la pandémie
depuis 2000 14e au classement
le prix de l'eau a augmenté de 30% et
les autres
énergies les autres charges ont
également énormément augmenté fusent
pourquoi on ne peut être pourquoi ça se
passe comme ça
précise t il c'est évident
l'ukraine a ravi
le patrimoine qu'elle avait le
patrimoine qu'elle avait hérité de
l'empiré russe mais aussi de l'urss
et si on prend
l'économie lé secteur obama
les secteurs des constructions
mécaniques les machines les outils
les
toutes ces
secteurs sont en déclin en 2022 on a
détruit l usine de construction des
bateaux en automne au feu
lucinde avion n'a pas produit d'avions
depuis des années où tiens je m'achète
qui
ainsi que crime une chose que
l'acier le combinat dassier
dit sont en déclin en ce qui concerne le
système de transport de gaz
il est très obsolètes qui conduit à des
risques énormes et à des dangers pour
l'écologie donc on voit la paupérisation
est ce que c'est ça le choix ou
occidental est-ce que c'est cela les
promesses qu'on fait à la population
depuis des années
donc l'économie de jeux créés n'étant
aux ruines c'est un pillage
de l'économie écoles et de la richesse
richesse nationale
cela est effectué avec la direction qui
vient de l'étranger des pays extérieurs
ou mais aussi des forces qui sont à
l'intérieur donc grâce aux différentes
organisations non gouvernementales
notamment et à travers les différentes
branches de pouvoir en influence
ou corrompre ou encore la poste créé
nien
il n'y a rien en ukraine
d'indépendance les gouvernements
gauchistes de l'ukraine
donner la possibilité
aux organisations étrangères 2 d'abord
le voit dans le choix des juges mais
l'ambassade de des états unis contrôlent
directement l' agence nationale de la
lutte contre la corruption euros le
routier corruption
le bureau du procureur anticorruption
la cour suprême anticorruption donc
il ya un prétexte ces aides à la lutte
anti corruption mais où est le résultat
la corruption prospère toujours plus
qu'avant
voilà les méthodes de gestion et de
gouvernance est ce que les yeux
craignant eux-mêmes souveraine ce qui se
passe en réalité l'ukraine est une
colonie avec un régime de marionnettes
le pouvoir ukrainien s'est dit patriote
mais en réalité ils sont en train de
détruire la souveraineté que chrétiens
et les luttes contre la langue aux
russes le parlement la rada continue
adopter de nouvelles lois notamment
prenons la loi contre les peuples
autochtones
on a fait comprendre à ses hôtes le
savons un peu plus aux us qui vivent en
ukraine que ce sont des étrangers
ensuite concernant où la langue russe
est la langue au russe est exclu de la
sphère publique des écoles et même des
magasins
ensuite aller
vers fonctionnaires
sont poursuivis s'ils ne sont pas une
commune conforme aux règles les
opposants sont poursuives il n'y a pas
de vraie
liberté d'expression on connaît les
sanctions
occidentales contre certains pays mais
les ukrainiens ont surpassé leurs
collègues occidentaux ils ont des pop-up
entrepris au des mercis que chanteuse
lorie propres
ou par exemple ligré l'église orthodoxe
du patriarcat russe également eut
réprimé et nous avons besoin de
décisions et des documents
tragédie de schisme religieux est devenu
un instrument de la politique sous le
par exemple les demandes du peuple
ukrainien
dénoncer les lois
sont orientés contre les personnes
croyantes donc bien au contraire ces
lois sont toujours là et on en prend de
nouveau et maintenant je voudrais parler
plus spécifiquement de la crimée le
peuple les citoyens qui vivent en crimée
11 mai leur choix ça c'est tout à fait
clair les autorités
ukrainiennes ne peuvent rien dit
agricole alors ils misent sur des
radicaux
sur des groupes
islamiques de diversion est l'homme
des personnes aux russes nous avons des
preuves directes que ces agressions se
rompt avec le soutien de l'étranger en
mars 21 l ukraine a adopté une nouvelle
stratégie militaire est au coeur de
cette stratégie
l'opposition à la russie et on essaie
d'impliquer dans cette
opposition des états étrangers on parle
on ne te laisses manqué
et d'ailleurs ont ils se voient déjà
l'issue de cette guerre
qui devrait avec l'aide de la communauté
internationale
conduire à la victoire de vie des
ukrainiens
avec le soutien aux militaires de la
communauté internationale dans
l'opposition militaire avec la russie
voilà ça c'est des mots qui sont dans la
doctrine ukrainienne
entendez vous cela également nous avons
déjà entendu des déclarations et
chrétiennes comme quoi l'ukraine est
prête à jeu acquérir des armes
nucléaires et ce n'est pas que des
paroles vaines l'ukraine à un certain
héritage
l'union soviétique
notamment l'aviation des missiles
d'ojika ou avec une portée de plus de
100 kilomètres donc les armes tactiques
nucléaires serait plus beaucoup plus
facile à acquérir pour lui traîne par
rapport à d'autres c'est à je ne vais
pas les nommer et donc si en plus il ya
un soutien de l'étranger ce serait
encore plus facile non nous devons
l'accepter c'est le permettre au mieux 6
à luxeuil acquiert les armes de
destruction massive nos relations avec
l'ukraine changerait totalement
nous ne faisons pas ne pas réagir
surtout que nous comprenons bien que les
parrains de l'étranger sont prêts à
aider l'ukraine nous voyons comment on
n'arrête pas de congrès de nouvelles
chutes les deux nouvelles armes en
ukraine depuis 2014 les états unis ont
employé des milliards de dollars en
formant des spécialistes en fournissant
des
armements et depuis quelques mois il ya
un flux ininterrompu
devant les yeux de tout le monde des
armes qui entrent en ukraine nous avons
nous savons que l'ukraine aura des
conseillers étrangers nous savons
également que sous prétexte des
exercices militaires annuels d'iliad et
qu'il retrouve de l'otan qui se sont
présents sur le sol et craignant donc
mais tu l'as lu commandement le prix
monte différentes unités ukrainienne
peut être effectuée directement des de
l'état major de l'otan donc ils ont
commencé déjà
considéré l'ukraine comme un théâtre
puis
seulement pardon l'année dernière il y
avait des exercices
militaires avec la partition de l'otan
et il ya une loi et rim qui prévoit la
participation à des exercices militaires
avec la participation des troupes
étrangères on comprend très bien qu'il
s'agit toujours du temps
donc ces événements
sans prétexte pour augmenter la présence
militaire de l'otan
sur tout le territoire de l'ukraine tu
voyais vous déjà vu boris folle tous ces
aéroports
permettront de pouvoir
accueillir des armements et des troupes
de l'otan l'espace aérien est ouvert
ouchakov les américains ont construit en
centre maritime qui permet de
communiquer avec oh les beaux bâtiments
militaires dans la mer noire dans les
vêtements militaires de l'otan ce cher
les etats unis font penser également
créer ce genre de vases en crimée mais
les habitants de la grille mais de
sébastopol on déjouer ses plans 11 on va
toujours se souvenir d'eux mais
aujourd'hui à ocz accord ce plan a déjà
été mis en oeuvre je dois vous rappeler
en au xviiie siècle
soldat de
souvorov ont combattu pour ce port et au
xviiie siècle ces terres
ont reçu le nom de novo russia suite à
la guerre entre la russie et la turquie
aujourd'hui on essaie de l'oublier on
essaie d'oublier les noms de ces 1 goran
au commandant militaire
on n'entend pas poltava récemment on a
démantelé l'urca ce monument à alexandre
souvorov qu'est ce que je peux dire vous
fils qu'il essayait de réécrire
l'histoire c'est votre histoire au
colonial vous
essayez de rayer
je voudrais rappeler également que la
constitution vous que 2010 cède
l'ukrainienne interdit l'installation
des bases militaires étrangères mais on
a trouvé une solution aujourd'hui il y
assure des missions de l'otan sur le
territoire ukrainien on a juste changé
de nom à quille et vont a confirmé le
cap stratégique
d'entrée dans le temps bien sûr chaque
pays a le droit de décider de ses
alliances mais
les différents textes internationaux
on parle du principe que de la sécurité
indivisible on ne peut pas construire sa
propre sécurité aux dépens de la
sécurité des autres je voudrais citer la
charteuse d'istanbul de le essaie
également de la déclare déclaration
d'astana 2010
c'est écrit dans ces documents donc la
sécurité de certains états ne doit pas
diminuer la sécurité des autres
je voudrais rappeler également qu'en
2018 il ya eu le sommet de bucarest de
l'otan et les états unis ont obtenu la
décision comme la géorgie
et l'ukraine deviendront
des membres de l'otan évidemment tout le
monde comprenait les risques qui sont
liées à cette décision mais les autres
pays n'ont pu rien dire face à
l'hégémonie deux des états unis
bien sûr viande et beaucoup de membres
de l'otan qui sont assez sceptiques
concernant l'entrée de l'ukraine à
l'otan et les différentes capitales
européennes de 10 cela m'a même les
américains eux mêmes ça ne se passera
pas demain mais pour nous que ça ça
demain ou après demain cela ne change
rien
nous savons ce que les dirigeants des
états unis jeudi ils ont eu d'immeubles
celia
s'il ya même un conflit militaire actif
sur le territoire ukrainien si d'autres
conditions sont réunies cela n'empêchera
pas les lieux ni de rentrer dans le
temps et en même temps on nous dit le
temps est une alliance défensive on se
propose de croire sur parole mais on
connaît le prix de cette parole en
1990 quand on parlait de la
réunification de l'allemagne
les etats unis ont promis allure
est-ce qu'il n'y aura pas
d'élargissement de la juridique
juridiction ou de l'eau du tangue vers
l'est
donc la réunification de l'allemagne ne
conduira pas à l'élargissement de l'otan
le merle est sûre on a beaucoup parlé on
nous a promis
c'était à l'oral mais c'était tout les
basses proposées
en suite on nous a dit que
l élargissement de l'otan vers les pays
de l'europe de l'espace pour contraire
les rassurer et améliorer les relations
entre ces pays et la russie mais
évidemment c'était bien le contraire
c'est pays bien au contraire
ont utilisé alors russophobie et on
insisté pour augmenter le potentiel
de l'otan dans les années 90 dans les
années 2000
ça se passait à l'époque le ou la russie
au compréhension par tous ses moyens sa
bonne volonté et l'a rempli tous ses
engagements et la sortie
unités militaires lieu de deux
l'allemagne de l'est et
d'autres territoires et on
a montré notre bonne volonté à coopérer
notamment au sein du conseil russie otan
et je vais dire quelque chose que je
n'avais encore jamais dit publiquement
c'est la première fois que je les tire
en l'an 2000 quant aux lieux président
bill clinton à la femme samantha
est venu avec la visite sommes chez nous
je lui ai posé la question comment les
états unis réagiront
à l'idée que la russie adhère à l'otan
je veux partir exactement
comment il a réagi
c'était une réaction modérée et
est donc on voit ensuite ce qui s'est
passé ils ont soutenu les terroristes
bien au contraire
donc ils n'ont pas du tout écouté nos
demandes
les demandes concernant j'ai le traité
anti missile non élargissement de l'otan
et 7 heures on se pose vraiment la
question pourquoi faire tout cela vous
ne voulez pas qu'on soit votre allié me
pourquoi faire de nous votre ennemi mais
il n'y a qu'une seule réponse ce n'est
pas lié à notre régime politique tout
simplement ils n'ont ne veulent pas
avoir un gang du pays en dépendant comme
la russie c'est ça la réponse c'est ça
la source de la politique traditionnelle
américaine envers la russie c'est pour
cela qu'ils ont c'est at-il sud
concernant notre proposition concernant
la sécurité il suffit de regarder la
carte pour voir comment les états unis
ont rempli leur engagement de ne pas
permettre l'élargissement de l'otan vers
l'est nous avons
cinq
d'élargissement la pologne
chi chi l'ha en client 99 ensuite la
bulgarie la lettonie slovaquie slovénie
albanie
bulgarie
la macédoine du nord et le monténégro
donc cinq vagues d'élargissement et le
temps est venu aux frontières de l'art
si et voilà c'est la source et
l'explication de la crise de la sécurité
c'est à dire que la confiance mutuelle a
été perdu et la situation continue à se
dégrader
notamment dans la sphère stratégique en
roumanie et en pologne dans le cadre du
système
antimissile on est en train de préparer
le terrain pour les missiles
donc on sait que ces installations
peuvent être utilisée pour les missiles
tombent entre ce sont des armes
offensives ensuite le missile standard 6
ça c'est un missile qui peut attendre
les cibles au sol et à la surface des
mers c'est à dire que les états unis
acquièrent de nouvelles capacités
offensives nous avons des informations
qui nous permettent de considérer
les choses que l'idée de l'adhésion de
l'ukraine à l'otan et du déploiement de
tous ces systèmes c'est une décision qui
a déjà été prise c'est juste une
question mais bel
et bien sur les dangers pour la russie
augmente énormément et surtout bien eu
lieu dans celle d'en haut d'une frappe
inattendue
et
dans la doctrine
militaire
américaine on sait très bien qu'il est
possible d'avoir une fois pas seul de
prévention est qui et qui
ont lieu les nuits des états unis c'est
la russie on connaît bien et on compte
l'otan considère que la russie est le
principal danger non sans s'être nous
nous aurais jamais cru s'ils avaient
entendu cela et nous ne voulons pas le
croire mais c'est ainsi et je voudrais
que tout le monde comprenne en russie et
en ukraine des aéroports une clients
souvent sont situés près de la russie
donc si le temps a dit dale ici
des missiles pourront entendre volgograd
samara kazan astrakhan y est les cités
mode de
de renseignement et de reconnaissance
dans le temps pourrait également avoir
un grand rayon d'action et en ce qui
concerne
les missiles de petites et moyennes
depuis que le
à traiter est finie a été dénoncé les
etats unis travaillent sur la création
de missiles de portée de 5500 kilomètres
moins de 35 minutes il faudra pour les
missiles tomahawk up attendre les cibles
en russie et seulement 4 5 minutes pour
les missiles et hyper sonic
dans ce cas je suis sûr qu'ils
espèrent réaliser non
comme ils ont fait quand ils ont élargi
l'otan vers l'est en avançant leurs
systèmes erp frontières ils ont
totalement ignoré
et bafoué nos demandes et nos
préoccupations ils nous font ils n'ont
fait que ce qu'il voulait et je suis sûr
qu'ils vont elles continuer à faire
comme avant c'est à dire le chien aboie
la caravane passe bien sûr nous n'avons
jamais accepté ce principe et nous
n'accepterons jamais et la russie a
toujours dit que il faut résoudre les
problèmes les plus complexes grâce à la
diplomatie et nous comprenons notre
responsabilité on va la stabilité
régionale en 2008 elle a réussi
à proposer une initiative dans nouveau
système de sécurité
je propose est justement qu'aucun pays
ne puisse augmenter sa sécurité au
détriment de la sécurité des autres pays
mais tout de suite on a ressuscité notre
proposition parce qu'on nous a dit et la
russie ne peut pas limiter les activités
de l'otan et que uniquement les membres
de l'alliance 'le atlantique peuvent
avoir des obligations juridiques
nous avons également transmis
en
décembre
dernier
en projet de traité et des garanties de
sécurité sécurité
qu'est ce que les états unis nous ont
répondu aux pouilles ou de paroles vague
il y avait quelques paroles rationnelle
mais très peu ils ont essayé de diluer
la discussion évidemment nous avons
réagi de manière appropriée nous avons
dit que nous sommes prêts à poursuivre
discussion cependant nous allons
discuter tout cela sous forme d'une
danse l ensemble il ya trois points clés
dans ce paquet de propositions un nom
élargissement de l'otan le
renoncement de l'otan d'installer des
systèmes offensive et ensuite le retour
à la posture de le temps en 1997 quand
été signé l'acte fondateur
russie otan donc cessons d nous avons
une parure de principe pour nous qu'ils
ont et lignes totalement je négligeais
les états unis et l'otan
répond évidemment que chaque état a le
droit de choisir ses alliances et à
choisir sa politique l'assurance de
sécuriser mais on n'arrête pas
d'entendre
cela
on nous répond encore et encore la même
chose en plus on nous fait du chantage
avec des sanctions mais les sanctions de
toute façon ils vont introduire ces
sanctions alors ce qu'est la russie va
renforcer sa souveraineté
et on va devenir de plus en plus fortes
on trouvera toujours en direct pour
rentrer les sanctions plus sévères ça
n'a rien à voir avec la situation en
ukraine parce qu'ils n'ont qu'un seul
objectif de limiter le développement de
la russie ils ont toujours fait
uniquement parce que nous existons parce
que nous défendons notre souveraineté
non valeur nationale
je voudrais dire de manière à sochaux
tout à fait direct nous avons fait des
propositions et
ils ont été totalement négligé les
menaces augmentent donc la russie a le
droit de prendre toutes les mesures pour
assurer sa propre sécurité c'est ça que
nous allons faire en ce qui concerne la
situation dans le donbass ce que nous
voyons c'est que le gouvernement au
pouvoir à kiev ne veulent pas me mettre
en oeuvre les accords de minsk ils ne
veulent pas de solutions possibles
pacifique bien au contraire ils veulent
refaire dans le donbass un blitzkrieg
comme cela a été fait en 2014-2015
sait comment ça s'est terminé
aujourd'hui nous avons des tirs
pratiquement tous les jours
nous voyons l'utilisation des drones de
l'artillerie des systèmes de lance
roquettes multiples on a des
victimes à on a des tirs envers les
populations civiles des femmes et les
enfants on est mieux on n'en voit pas la
fin et le soi disant
civilisé qu'est ce qu'il fait tu te nos
collègues occidentaux pensent que c'est
eux qui représente mon civilisé mais
préfère ne rien remarquer fait fermer
les yeux à tous ces horreurs au génocide
contre les 4 millions de personnes
uniquement parce que ces personnes n'ont
pas accepté le coup d'état en ukraine en
2014 qui a été soutenue par les pays
occidentaux
donc si on voit ce mouvement vers le
nationalisme agressif
le nationalisme de cavernes les gens
n'ont pas le droit d'utiliser leur
propre langue de
sauvegarder leurs traditions culturelles
c'est une véritable tragédie mais
combien encore pourra-t-on supporter
cette tragédie et la russie a tout fait
pour
sauvegarder et préserver l'intégrité
territoriale de l'ukraine
et notamment respecter la résolution 22
02 de 2015 du conseil de sécurité de
l'union nous avons tout fait enfin on
voit les présidents changent et on voit
les députés de la rade a changé oh mais
le régime à kiev ne change pas parce que
c'est un régime qui est venu suite ou
dessin en 2014 ils ont choisi la voie de
l'effusion du sang de la violence et ils
n'ont pas
d'autre objectif que d' utiliser la
violence dans le débat c'est donc je
pense que dans ce contexte nous ne
pouvons pas faire autre chose peu parce
que reconnaître la souveraineté de la
république populaire de donner ce qu'est
la république populaire de lougansk je
demande au conseil de fédération de
soutenir cette décision donc et de
signer les documents en conséquence ces
documents seront préparés signer très
rapidement
je m'adresse à ceux qui ont fait le coup
d'état et qui garde le pouvoir à kiev je
leur demande d'arrêter
les activités militaires dans ces
régions et la suite de l' effusion du
sang alors serra amputait jeu donc je
vous annonce cette décision et je suis
sûr que toutes les forces patriotiques
de mon pays les soutiendrons tout le
peuple russe les soutiendra je vous
remercie pour votre attention